SAMANTHA POWERS HAS NO BUSINESS
AT ALL I'M ASKING 300 PEOPLE LET
ALONE ONE.
PROFESSOR, WE ALREADY KNOW WHAT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS GOING TO
SAY, BECAUSE HE SAID IT OVER THE
THREAT OF PERJURY, I HAVE NO
IDEA IF ANY OF THE DOSSIER IS
TRUE, HILLARY PAID FOR IT, AND
YES, I HATE DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE
HE TOLD EVERYBODY, BUT THEY
STILL USED IT AS THE BULK OF
INFORMATION TO GET THE FISA
WARRANT AGAINST NOT ONLY CARTER
PAGE, BUT A BACKDOOR TO ALL
THINGS TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
TRANSITION, AND PRESIDENCY.
>> I'M GLAD THAT HE IS
TESTIFYING OR AT LEAST APPEARING
IN FRONT OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, THE QUESTIONS THAT
THEY WILL PUT TO HIM IN ORDER TO
TRY TO PROTECT THE INVESTIGATION
TRY TO PROTECT THE INVESTIGATIOW
TRY TO PROTECT THE INVESTIGATIOL
BE BASED ON CHRONOLOGY.
WHEN DID YOU REALIZE THAT THE
REPORT WAS NOT AS VALID AND
SOLID AS YOU ORIGINALLY THOUGHT
IT WAS?
WHEN DID YOU LEARN THAT IT WAS
PAID FOR BY DEMOCRATS?
THAT WAS DISCLOSED, BECAUSE WHAT
HE SAID UP TO NOW IS THE REPORT
ITSELF IS NOT VALID.
BUT WHAT WE NEED TO KNOW IS WHEN
THEY KNEW IT, AND WHAT THEY DID
ABOUT IT.
AND DID ANYBODY MISREPRESENT?
WHAT THEY KNEW AT ANY PARTICULAR
TIME.
>> Sean: PROFESSOR, IT IS AN
UNVERIFIABLE DOCUMENTS, BECAUSE
ITS AUTHORS SAID HE CANNOT STAND
BY IT.
AND IN OCTOBER --
BRUCE OHR WARNED EVERYONE IN
2016, WE KNOW TWO WEEKS BEFORE
COMEY SIGNED THE FISA
APPLICATION, HE WAS WARNED
AGAIN.
AND THERE WERE OTHER WARNINGS.
AND HE STILL PUTS HIS SIGNATURE
ON A SPYING DOCUMENT, HE DENIES
SPYING ON NOT ONLY CARTER PAGE,
BUT AN OPPOSITION PARTY.
>> RAW INTELLIGENCE LIKE THAT
SHOULD NEVER BE THE BASIS FOR A
FISA WARRANT THAT INTRUDES ON
THE RIGHTS OF AMERICAN CITIZENS
PRIVACY.
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE THAN THAT.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE COMPLETE
CANDOR FROM ANYBODY WHO SIGNED A
FISA WARRANT.
THEY HAVE TO TELL THE COURT.
WE HAVE THIS, WE ARE NOT SURE
HOW VALID IT IS.
THE AUTHOR --
>> Sean: THEY NEVER TOLD THE
COURT, HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
>> IT IS SOMETHING IN A
FOOTNOTE, BUT THEY INTENDED TO
MISLEAD THE COURT INTO THINKING
THAT THEY HAD AN INCREDIBLE